all right everybody thank you for coming
um this is a
dionysius circle event so sam
me
carson and then we have a few other
members we are
we founded this thing called the
dionysia circle it's devoted to the
study of dionysius the areopagite
and his influence on the christian
philosophic traditions you can
find our website and join our mailing
list if you're interested
we'll be having some more of these
events
and
our main focus in this group is to kind
of study the neoplatonic tradition and
anselm's a key figure here he was
heavily influenced by augustine who was
in turn influenced by platinus
and so we would like to welcome dr
gregory sadler to this event to do a
presentation on anselm and then after
the presentation we'll open up some
questions feel free anybody to just
raise your hand or
interject if there's a there's a space
and gregory dr gregory b sadler is a the
author of reason fulfilled by revelation
which is a
book on the christian philosophy debates
in france in the 1930s and he's also
authored a bunch of articles on topics
from anselm to jacques lacan
and of course you as you all know he's
the famous youtuber
with the thousands of videos i think
over 2000 videos now on philosophic
topics
so
dr schadler take it away
thanks so thanks to the dionysus circle
i'm really happy to see this uh
sort of initiative going on thanks to
jack for the
invitation to present um
anselm
is a thinker who i've been
grappling with for about a quarter of a
century and i never expected to become
like an handsome scholar but there's
there's something about the guy that is
really quite uh compelling
so
i'm supposed to speak for about half an
hour um
i haven't actually timed this
presentation i might go over
considerably
and
i've been a little bit under the weather
lately so if i
you know
if there's anything that's unclear i'm
going to blame it on that and not on
anselm or anything in his thought
and then you know once i'm done i'm
happy to field whatever questions you've
got for me or to follow out threads of
discussion
um once i've said my part for anselm i'm
at your disposal and a lot of what i'm
going to be doing is is simply telling
you what it is that anselm himself
says and trying to put together
you could call them pieces of a complex
puzzle that anselm himself is
not
articulating quite that way he's he's
got different you know if we want to mix
metaphors different fish to fry
so
this talk is exploring the attribute of
divine simplicity and anselm's works and
then to a certain extent how it how it
plays out in the trinity
and what we find out you know i think
fairly quickly when we look at anselm's
works uh even just with the monologian
is that simplicity is not as simple a
matter for us as we
would typically think it to be or want
it to be and that
wanting it to be simpler or wanting it
to be a certain kind of simplicity that
it's not gets us into a lot of trouble
and we can we can talk maybe in the q a
about you know anselm's views on how the
intellect and will are connected and
this is a matter that anselm really
devoted a lot of thought to um and i do
want to say that you know the the
thought that anselm devoted to it we get
to see the tip of the iceberg in the
written works and also in his prayers
and his letters and and stuff like that
there's much more to anselm's thinking
than what than the traces that we find
in his treaties
the other thing i'll say is that his
thought is not static
so he's not proceeding in a syllogistic
manner saying ah i've established point
a now let's move on to point b it's
really quite fluid and
dialectical and the dialectic to make it
even more complicated is not just you
know between ideas or within ourselves
it's or within our mind or language it's
a direct engagement with god
and god turns out to be kind of a weird
weird being we'll say
in um
anselm's works but one around which
everything else
is going to be
centered and so
as we're working through his his
treatises and the ideas in them
if if we're doing it right there should
be kind of a transformation that's
taking place in our thinking and and
thinking is an activity for
somebody like anselm there are some
interpreters that are very well attuned
to this the entire french reflective
tradition which would include you know
writers like henry de lubeck and jacques
paliar who write about this um some of
the more recent english writers um
on anselm you know like gr evans
and um
um oh i'm blanking on her name she's at
boston college and i can see her right
in front of my face maybe i'll recall it
later on but they're eileen sweeney
they're very good at at sort of bringing
out this dynamic aspect to anselm's
thought as well
so
i'm going to
get started with the actual talk in a
bit but
after just a bit of digression we'll
look at anselm's examination of the
divine attributes
mostly in the monologian and then we'll
focus in on
one of those
simplicity and its implications and then
we'll shift to looking at
how anselm thinks about god as as a
trinity in in his works because you know
that kind of naturally comes to mind if
god is simple then what's this three
business right
so the main texts that i think are the
most germane are two of his earliest
treatises the monologian and the
pro-slogan and then two later occasion
texts one is on the incarnation of the
word
and the other is on the procession of
the holy spirit i'm not going to talk
much about the second one
and you know in part just to try to keep
things as short as possible
before the digression though one other
remark so i'm going to treat all of you
here in the audience like anselm treats
his critic ganilo responding not to the
fool but to the christians so to speak
it's possible to
be very unsympathetic to anselm's point
of view and his works and thought
he is as kate rogers wrote an entire
book about early in her career which was
her dissertation at notre dame and then
turned into her first book a christian
platonist
and you know i'm guessing here you know
with the dionysus circle i don't have to
make a case for you know platonism being
a good thing or anything like that but
you know other people will watch this
and i just want to point out
that one of the things that kate rodgers
writes about in an article
is that you know you could you could you
could say about ansem well i'm not a
christian platonist so i don't have to
buy any of his stuff
and you know rogers points out the sort
of thing that aleister mcintyre has
pointed out in his works nobody comes
from a purely neutral metaphysical
perspective you know and
rogers argues i think quite persuasively
why
christian platonism could be a very
good starting point particularly if the
goal is to understand what anselm is
getting at it's at least as good and
reasonable as as others one might adopt
in the present i would say so
the digression
by way of preparation i'm not going to
assume any great familiarity on your
part with anselm and i just want to say
a few things he's one of the great
benedictine monastic thinkers
he's from a noble family and he
left that behind
settled upon a monastic life and what
does that mean so the monastic life was
called by that time christian philosophy
and
it was you know it took a lot of
different forms even just within the
benedictine order at back where he was
it took a particularly intellectual form
so you've got prayer community work
study teaching obedience in anselm's
case the exercise of authority and rule
that he never asked for but wound up
getting stuck with he ends up becoming
archbishop of canterbury
and he's an unusual thinker for his time
you can assume that anselm
would have read and you know re-read
everything that was available to him in
monastery libraries and we know that
things are circulating from libraries to
libraries because we see people bug you
know bugging him about can you send me
gregory's moralia and job so we can copy
it over here so you know that's going to
include a lot of pagan authors like
seneca and cicero
it's going to include all the church
fathers some of whom he'll reference
occasionally just as the church fathers
augustine of course as jack has pointed
out
um alcuin
later thinkers you know like alkyne and
boethius or uh john scottis eragina
but unlike
most of the other thinkers of his time
anselm almost never
cites or invokes authorities
so he's rather
unusual in that way which means that
oftentimes you know if we see something
we'll be like well did that come from
augustine it kind of looks like what's
going on there but you know anselm's not
citing him or did that come from
boethius yeah it could be you know we we
have to kind of guess at it
he also appears to have been an
extraordinarily gifted teacher
initiating students lesson to like the
life of the mind is something
set aside from and above the rest of
life and more into an integrated life
fully developing the minds that god has
endowed us with
which again i think fits in very well
with the platonic motif you know it's
not about contemplation as total
withdrawal from the world that you live
in
but rather
participating more fully in whatever is
uh being
understood through that
so you know the works like the
monologian the pro-slogan on the
incarnation of the word anselm
writes them
not to provide scholastic treatises on
anything
he
he's pestered basically into writing the
monologian by his fellow monks
because he's been teaching them and
they're like the stuff you teach is so
cool can you write it down for us and at
first he's like nah i'm not the guy for
that and then they keep bugging him and
bugging him so finally he does it and it
turns out to be this incredible
meditation on you know the divine
attributes and and the
trinity and things like that the
pro-slogan arises out of his attempt to
try to resolve the many arguments the
you know fabric or or contexture of many
arguments in the monologian into a
single argument the unum argumentum
and then once he's actually done that to
to share the joy
that he found in that so it's got a
emotional or aesthetic motivation behind
it on the incarnation of the word is um
him trying to respond to a local you
know uh essentially nominalist smart ass
rosslyn who was making arguments that
that god is either three gods or all
three persons became flesh and he gets
started on it and then rosalind gets you
know called up for heresy
recants anselm puts away his his
manuscript and then people start
circulating it without his his uh
knowledge or his consent then he returns
to it later on and because rosalind is
actually back on on the uh
you know arguments again
and so anselm you know works it into a
full treatise so he never writes this
stuff to you know like set the record
straight about it you know to create a
summer or anything like that it's a very
different kind of motivation
the last thing that i'll say by way of
digression before we get started there's
kind of a paradox about ansem
he's viewed by a lot of people
as an ultra rationalist because he'll
you know he'll try to prove the
incarnation and its logic or
um you know he'll get into the trinity
and try to explain that you know
tinkering around with the inner workings
you could say right
but he also is somebody who's sometimes
portrayed as a fetish
and you know where he is is somewhere in
between he he actually thinks that these
things can be explored and understood by
human reason to some extent but
you need some help and you need some
starting points and
you know he's um
he's really just as impressed as
augustine is by this
quote that comes from isaiah unless you
believe you will not understand coming
from the septuagint version of isaiah
and he you know he
takes as sort of his motto faith
seeking understanding so faith trying to
develop understanding on the basis on
the other hand you know he's not a well
we're going to start from you know faith
in a propositional way and that's going
to feed all of the input in and then
we'll just you know reason we'll we'll
do that no it's it's again much more
fluid and dynamic so let's start by
considering the divine attributes um
the divine attributes are what god is
and there are things that we can say
about
god that
you know the term that anselm uses in
the monologian is
substantive right so what can we say
about god
as
a substance as
um
the entity that god is and in monologian
15
he says it's okay to use relational
terms you know you can you can call god
for example supreme
but it doesn't actually tell you
anything
not not very helpful i mean
it's not going to resolve your problems
um
why why is supreme uh an issue well
because
take away the rest of creation and god
is no longer supreme god just is god
um so what is
god well we can look at non-relational
terms and anselm in the monologian says
that these are two kinds there's
those that
what that term signifies is in every
respect better than what its negation
signifies
and then there's some where its negation
is in some respect better than it so
examples of this because that sounds
pretty abstract true and not true it's
better to be true than not to be true
right
same thing like material object
non-material object in the case of
of
spirit and matter you know one is better
than the other but a prime example of
this is wisdom
anselm says it's always better to be
wise than not wise and not wise uh is
not
unqualifiedly better than wise so when
if you if you try to think of you know
situations where you're like well wait a
second
would it wouldn't it be better for me to
be not wise
if
being wise like got me into trouble or
you know
made me
feel bad or something like that and some
say well yeah that's qualified you know
you're making up some some hypothetical
that would you know allow you to say
that sort of thing you put that sort of
stuff aside being wise is going to be
better than not being wise same thing
with true
just living and as it's going to turn
out these you know it's always better to
be just than unjust right
so
what's an example of something and i
really like this example
of something that's
not always better golden right it's
better to be golden than lead if we're
just like comparing the two by
themselves
and i guess you know like if this this
cup was gold that would be kind of nice
you know i could sell it or something
like that it probably still would hold
coffee um
you know
coffee doesn't get so hot that it would
melt the gold but would it be good for
you to be made of gold no that would be
terrible right that would be essentially
the end of you as a human being
so
he goes on and he says that god or this
substance is alone that then which
nothing at all is better and it alone is
better than all things that are not what
it is
so god is going to be
living wise powerful all-powerful true
just these are you know sort of a
listing that he gives
in proslogian 5 he is going to say god
is whatever it is better to be than not
to be
if we go a little deeper into the
monologian
he says that
okay
we've got these
predicates that we can say about god god
is just god is good right
are they what are they telling us about
god are they telling us
what god is or are they telling us what
kind of thing god is
or how much god is qualis or qantas
and so he says um you know if we think
about justice
if god is just through participating in
justice then god is just through
something else
justice is in a certain way greater than
god then
god is just sort of the best or the the
justice thing compared to let's say the
platonic form of justice right
and so anselm says well that's not going
to work
god is going to be the very justice
through which god is just so you know if
we i invoke the platonic form the
platonic form of justice would be god
not god would be participating in in
that form
he even uses the word eustitia existence
that is um existing justice is you know
sort of a
immediate way to translate it or
um
god excelling in being as justice we
could if we wanted to be a little
periphrastic and so he says that okay so
this works for justice the intellect
discerns rationally that what we've
established of justice holds true for
everything predicated similarly of the
supreme nature and so he gives us a
longer list now he says that
the supreme nature is supreme being
ascentia supreme life supreme reason
supreme refuge supreme justice supreme
wisdom supreme truth i'm not going to go
through all of them
then he says
these are also the same as supremely
being
soma ends supremely living some of
events so
at least with the highest thing in in
each of these it's not just a static
thing it's dynamic and active
and god is not some sort of like super
substance that has all of these awesome
attributes god is these attributes
themselves
now in monologian 17
here's where we start to get to the
simplicity issue
anselm starts out with this really rich
multiplicity of all the best stuff these
these great attributes that god doesn't
just have but is
and is what everything else that just
has them participates in so you and i
are just because we participate in some
way in the
justice that is that is god we are
living because we participate in some
way in the the life that has got does
anselm ever explain this no
i mean with the justice part maybe a
little bit you know in terms of justice
as rectitude of will preserved for its
own sake and you know the discussions in
the other treaties
when it comes to the others like living
he doesn't he doesn't explain that at
all but what this does show us
is that god is all of these really great
attributes now
here's where we get to the simplicity
thing
can these be a multiplicity or plural or
different
if that was the case then god would be a
composite being and that can't be the
case according to anselm so he says the
whole necessity of previously
established truth destroys and
overthrows by means of clear reasoning
this blasphemous falsity which is pretty
strong language for ansem
and so what do we have then well all
these divine attributes
must be one
good signified by
many names
but
that raises some problems that we'll
we'll think about in just a bit he tells
us each attribute is the same edem as
all the others or rather all of them
omnia whether together
symbol or considered distinctly singular
and then he says this is what it means
to be simple simplex
so
when justice or being is spoken of the
same thing is signified
as the others whether all together or
distinctly now he doesn't by the way use
the word simplicitas in um that listing
in monologian 16. he's using unitas
unity instead right but these are going
to be the same thing and it gets you
know even trippier right because
that means that divine life is the same
thing as divine
goodness as divine reason as divine now
we get to even weirder attributes
eternity
or unity unity itself is the same as all
the things that it's unifying
and you know if your head starts
spinning when you hear this stuff that's
fine because
you know we're running through this very
quickly these are things you're supposed
to like meditate on over over a lot of
time
now in pro slogan chapter 18 he
approaches this this same issue and he
says there's no parts in god or the
eternity that god is
anselm asks for god's help at this point
because he admits he's in confusion and
darkness and neediness he needs god to
illuminate his intellect
and you know shortly after he says god
is all these good things and his mind
anselm's mind cannot see them all in one
glance or view so you know presumably
our our minds aren't going to get them
either even though we're thinking about
them and referencing them now
and then he says
whatever is made of parts is not
entirely one or a unity but in a sense
it's multiple and other than itself and
it can be broken up either actually
in octu or
um
in the mind
intellectual it can be dissolving
it can be broken up it can be analyzed
and so anselm is saying that god
isn't able to be broken up like that
even though you and i might think that
we can do that and we're doing you know
we're doing something like that right
now and listing off these divine
attributes and saying
yeah is god justice okay god's justice
over here and you know goodness over
here and then like maybe we'll put the
you know eternity over here and um
we we are the ones that are thinking of
things in that way and some showing us
that that's an inadequate way of
understanding things it's not really
even understanding things to see it that
way
so he concludes in prosology in chapter
18 by saying that god is unity itself
ipsa unitas
not divisible by any mind
and we could you know bring up other uh
texts as well de veritate 12 has you
know in god
will and rectitude are not different
there's no difference between power and
divinity and if we think about some of
the implications of this
we can say a few things that might be
good launching points a little bit later
on
so unity is one of the things that god
is but it also describes the relation
between all these things that god is
it turns out that they're all
they're all unity they're all the same
and
so
whatever we think simplicity is
we're probably
not getting it
we're
we've got a notion of simplicity or
unity
god's unity or simplicity is
beyond that which means that we don't
really know
what unity or simplicity is and we don't
really know
what reason is or any of these other
divine attributes that we've rattled off
now you know you can say well that means
we have to get really abstract in our
thinking maybe this is kind of a
negative theology
that's not really the direction anselm
is going though
in in his work
now that's a lot already to digest and i
i see i'm already you know getting close
to the time that i'm supposed to be
wrapping up but i do have a a good bit
more stuff i'll probably skip over uh
some of the stuff from from the uh
monologian
so
if we look at the trinity stuff right in
pro slogan there's only one chapter and
and all the chapters are pretty short in
the pro slogan he tells us um this good
is you this is in chapter 23 oh god the
father it is your word that is to say
your son for there cannot be anything
other than what you are or anything
greater less than you in the word by
which you utter
yourself and this is coming from the
monologue you know it's coming from you
know traditional christian theology
right the second person of the trinity
is the word um
who is also the son and then he says um
you are so simple that nothing can be
born of you then
that is other than what you are
and this good is the one love shared by
you and your son that is the holy spirit
who proceeds from you both this love is
not unequal to you
to you or to your son since you love
yourself and him and he loves himself
and you as much as you and he
are
um so you've got sort of a pretty
traditional exposition
very short of the trinity you know
you've got the the father
son is begotten of the father
holy spirit proceeds from both this is
something that will be a controversy
that anselm will get into with the
eastern
christians of course but
so
some of the things that he says there is
each person of the trinity individually
singular is the
torah trinita symbol is the entire
trinity at the same time potter athelius
at spiritual
right and it's also the summa simplex
unitas so the
um
the
supreme simple unity
at suma una
and the supreme
unified one however you want to say it
simply simplicity
so
simplicity itself is playing a bigger
role there and it's already you know
playing a role within this this notion
of god is
trinity um in the monologian which i'm
going to just kind of run through very
quickly and skip over some of the things
i was going to mention
um there's a lot of discussion of the
word as divine reason and utterance
of the things that that exist before
they're made and the word is the
understanding the intelligentsia of the
creating spirit
he calls this the summa sumplex nattora
the the supreme simple nature
and you know he spends a lot of chapters
sort of outlining how the the word and
the
the creator are are interconnected with
each other
and
he you know he says that it makes sense
to call this generation or being born um
obviously there's you know it's not like
um
natural birth or something like that uh
and and we would do wrong in order to
just try to analogize that into it right
um he's just he's saying this is the
best language that we have or the best
concepts that we have um the second is
born from the first the creator from the
creator the supreme from the supreme the
very same from the very same he says in
monologian 39
eventually he brings in the
love of the supreme spirit for itself
and this is the holy spirit which he
talks about in monologian 49 through 58.
um
what i'm gonna
you know i'm actually running through a
lot of stuff that you want to go back to
and and like dig around in but i'll i'll
bring it to close by by
saying this in in 63 he tells us that
whatever is essentially
present in the supreme nature
belongs completely to or
you know it applies completely to
perfect conventi
father son and their spirit
individually so the persons of the
trinity individual the singulatum
but if the same thing is said of all
three of them together it does not admit
of plurality
now what does all this mean so
think about god as being justice
this means that if you
call god justice
that's something that is present in the
supreme nature that belongs completely
to the father completely to the son and
completely to the spirit individually
so considering the father just on his
own or its own or whatever you know is
going on there uh and the son completely
on on his own or its own
it's completely just or it's not even
completely just it is complete justice
it is justice itself same thing with
goodness same thing with eternity same
thing with
simplicity this is where we start to get
very uh very trippy right
but that doesn't mean that there's three
different justices
that are
distinct from each other
there's only one
and
um so there aren't you know three
justices or three eternities or three
unities
and there's only one father and one son
and one spirit who proceeds from there's
not like a son of the son or a father of
the father or any of that sort of thing
he clarifies
he ends the monologian
well not completely ends but gets close
to the ending
bringing us in
and saying in a typically augustinian
manner that all of you i think who are
familiar with augustine will recognize
that the rational human mind
is an approach to an image and mirror a
very you know
imperfect one
of this divine substance so the human
rational mind remembering
understanding and loving itself and the
trinity which also
is
you know capital r remembering capital u
understanding capital l
loving
that is how we get to know
the the trinity
and notice one thing before we go on to
the incarnation of the word
in the monologian and the pro-slogan
anselm doesn't do what some people
do
on occasion
which is to like invoke some higher
faculty that we have
by which we would grasp the divine
i mean you see something like that in
boethius right where um you've got
you know the senses and then
imagination
and then reason
and then or you know the intellect would
also be there and then you've got this
whatever you want to call it
intelligence intuition something like
that
which we don't really have but but is
the way that god understands
uh god's self um anselm doesn't do
anything like that he's he's much more
on the one hand confident about our our
capacities to use our our cognitive
faculties to get this sort of thing and
he's also more circumspect in saying
well we're
we're not going to get this entirely a
lot of this is gonna remain you know
just dimly glimpsed by us
when we go on to the on the incarnation
of the word
um which i'm again i'm not gonna like
hit on everything i just wanted to bring
up a few interesting points
so there's this guy rosslyn right and
and rosslyn is a typical
i mentioned him as a smart ass earlier
that's basically what he is you know
he's he's somebody who's making
arguments
and claiming you know the sort of well
you know if you believe this then you
must also be committed to this or this
so therefore you know your your thoughts
your your understanding is a muddle you
know you you orthodox christians
and
he um
he's basically arguing this
um
with the trinity idea
you christians who are supposed to
defend yourself against you know pagans
and jews and and muslims
you're not doing a very good job because
your your notion of the trinity either
winds up with god being three gods and
you clearly don't want that because you
know you define that as heresy earlier
or
every person of the trinity
is equally incarnate
so it's not just the son who becomes
human you know or takes on humanity
however you want to talk about it it's
also the father and the holy spirit at
the same time and this is you know this
is a trap from which you christians
cannot escape
you know and anselm comes along and he
he's got an interesting set of responses
he calls rosslyn one of those
dialecticians dialecti who
he actually uses um
that several times in there who think
that universal substances are just
vocalizations
and he says that the power of reason in
their souls is so bound up in corporeal
imaginations
uh imagination corpalibus
that they cannot extricate themselves
from this
they can't distinguish between
their imaginations
from the matters that they should
contemplate now he's not like saying
don't imagine things
you know
imagination is totally inapplicable to
god or anything like that
what he is saying is that sort of like
with boethius right there is a hierarchy
of uh human faculties
and imagination
you know if we want to be kind of
hegelian about this we could call it
representation or picture thinking you
know
that's not going to be
adequate to a higher
reality that can't be pictured in that
way
and so to insist upon that
is
setting yourself up and your
interlocutors
for misunderstanding things
so
in chapter 4
he tells us if you have a simple
intellect and you know simplicity is
entering in here right simplicum hobbit
intellectum
not one
that is
bound up or
buried in a
multiplicity of
phant the the the latin word there is
actually
phantasmatum
so it's no longer just uh imagination
but you could say
particular imaginations then we
understand that simple things
exceed or surpass or excel composite
things
and then he goes on and says if god is
composed of three things
then
we have a problem
either there's no simple substance
at all
or
sorry
there's another substance
that in some way surpasses god
so you know what we see here is
something
similar for those of you who are
familiar with the prosologian
argument about the being or existence of
god which gets used throughout the
prosology and right quo mayas kogitari
known posit that you know which is not a
definition of god by the way anselm says
but a way of understanding god sort of a
rule if there's anything that's greater
than god
god isn't god
you didn't whatever it was that you were
calling god
wasn't god
no augustine also says stuff like this
right in um
on
free choice of the will and in in other
places if you can imagine something
that's better than god
something has gone wrong somewhere you
you you know the whatever you're calling
god
isn't is just sort of a
well a phantasm or an imagination
not really an understanding
of the divine and if you think there's
something that's going to going to be
the criterion or canon or judge or that
god is going to be subject to you may as
well start worshiping that thing because
it's it's the greatest thing
now anselm
points out another part of the another
you could say aspect to this
a person claiming that god is composite
says that he can understand something
greater than god so that
the human intellect goes beyond god
something that no intellect can actually
do although we can we can
lie to ourselves or deceive ourselves
into thinking that we can actually
understand something greater than god
and that's what he thinks that rosalind
is doing and you know
not just rosslyn i think he would think
a lot of people are doing that sort of
thing so
instead we have to look at god as being
completely simple
and yet being a trinity
in chapter 8 he says the supreme good
does not allow multiplication of itself
into several supreme goods
there's only one supreme substance one
supreme essence or nature
and then in nine he says the father and
the son are the same substance the one
in the same substance but
with respect to person they are multiple
and distinct from each other this is how
we can get our
heads around it
god doesn't assume a human being into
god's substance
the son the the single uh person the son
assumes a human being into the unity of
his person the son became flesh by
reason of the unity of the person and
then in
uh chapter 11 he goes on to say there
aren't two persons in christ
there is a divine and human nature in
one person so we've got a couple we've
got a lot of like
you know metaphysics terms playing a big
role there right a lot of distinctions
going on
but this is how anselm
makes sense of that
and then you know a little bit later on
going back to these sort of
how we understand our understanding it
says if if his adversary doesn't
understand all this
let him understand there's things in god
that his intellect could not understand
let him not compare the nature that is
superior to everything the nature free
from every law of time and space and
composition of parts
to things that are characterized in that
way instead let him profess that there
are in that nature the divine right what
cannot be in the latter things
in 15 he's going to say that god is
nothing but simple eternity itself ipsa
simplex iternitas there are not several
eternities like there's not an eternity
of the father an eternity the son and an
eternity of the holy spirit
but there is a
repetition or
a nice translation for this in um
the
i think is the
yeah davies and evans uh one is
replication um i like to think of this
as as part of what goes on with these
divine attributes
and how active they are there is a
intensive reflexity
involved in there so he says that um
god is a nature that is replicated upon
itself always one with itself in perfect
unity the latin there is
a
repetitive
in perfectam unitatum
and because this is the case god is of a
higher rank
digniour
god is the highest rank really
than what admits of plurality and we can
say that about other things not just
eternity
but also so there you know it's not as
if there's an eternity inside of an
eternity but eternity is itself
reflected upon itself same thing with
divine justice same thing
with goodness same thing with
simplicity weirdly enough right
and this allows us to at least partly
cognize
what these divine attributes are like in
god how simplicity is we understand it
is not quite the same thing as the real
simplicity that is god
he tells us in 16 that the divine
substance preserves an eternal and
unique
unity
and at the same time has an inseparable
plurality
of these relations that that allow god
to be understood as father son holy
spirit right
so god you can't have the trinity and
unity at the same time
and
you know
it's not going to be like any other
thing it's not going to be like you know
st patrick supposedly holding up the
clover with three three parts to it or
anything like that nevertheless and this
is this is where i wanted to end
anselm does provide us with an analogy
in in on current in on the incarnation
of the word
um which he admits is not a great one
but nevertheless he'll throw out there
anyway and then reappropriate in on the
procession of the holy spirit so
he says imagine the nile
and he doesn't mean like the real nile
in egypt he's just talking about it as
you know a fictional thing there's a
sorry there's a source
a beginning you know of it uh a river or
a stream and then a delta in the later
uh reappropriation he'll call it a lake
right
and each of these individually is called
the nile
if you put two of them together so like
the source and the river that's also
called the nile you put all three of
them together that's also called the
nile and it's the same water going
through
all of them the running water the water
that's in motion
is one it's not three running waters or
three bodies of waters or three
substances
and yet you can distinguish between the
source which is not from the river or
the delta the river is not from the
delta
the entire river is from the entire
source and the entire delta is from the
entire source in the entire river you're
probably seeing the parallelism here
right just like the
sun is entirely from the father
entirely begotten and the holy spirit
proceeds from both the entire father and
the entire son right
and so
he says that the you know this this
works for understanding the trinity and
then you can say well what about the
incarnation of the word what about
taking on flesh
well
that's like taking a pipe and having
that river now no longer flow through
the land
but through a pipe it's still flowing
right
and you still have all the same
relations between things it's just
becoming piped just like the
sun has become incarnate
now anselm says after he provides this
this isn't very good
don't be misled by this
but
in on the procession of the holy spirit
he he apparently thinks it's good enough
to bring up again
and he says that he adds to it he says
the water rising from the depths bubbles
up in the spring or the source
descending from the spring flows into
the stream or the river and is collected
and stays in the lake
the stream is not
such from what we call water or spring
but from what the stream is that is the
water and and you know so on so you know
god whatever god is the attributes god
is
is what the father is and the son is and
and the holy spirit and though their
relations are maintained without god
losing god's simplicity or unity even
though there is a plurality in that you
can even have enough of a seeming
plurality
that one of them
can be um
in the case of the incarnation of the
word can be incarnate without the others
being so
you can also have you know the big
concern about
the on the procession of the holy spirit
one of them proceeding from the other
two
without losing that that um unity or
simplicity
as well
and so
how do we put all this together this is
this is where we can kind of wrap up and
then we'll open it up for discussion and
i imagine some of the discussions like
what the hell was that about you know
um
we've got these these attributes each of
which is what god is
so it's not as if they're separate or
god exists prior to them
as a matter of fact
justice is just as good a name for god
as god is or goodness or
you know anything else right
um and they're all the same
so they're
they're distinguishable
by us
to some degree but you kind of get the
idea that in anselm's mind
in god these are not
separated things these are not even
distinct things god's eternity is the
same thing as god's justice
hard thing for us to wrap our heads
around i think right i know it certainly
is for me i won't speak for all of you
um i'd be very pleased if one of you is
like no no i totally understand it and
here's and then you like you know laid
out exactly how that works because i've
been you know wrapping my head around
this for for quite a while so we've got
that on the one hand
and then we've got
all this trinity business
on the other hand
they're all one unity
and at the same time
there's enough going on here to allow
one of the persons
of that trinity
to be incarnate and to even be like
prayed to in in prayers and psalm has a
prayer to christ right so this is not
abstract metaphysics at all this is
trying to penetrate into the
heart of what ultimately it has to be
conceited to be a mystery but not a
mystery in the sense that like we throw
up our hands oh we just don't understand
any of this stuff you know um we'll just
you know stick with negative theology
and and you know um
not say we know anything no we're being
invited to to try to you know as best as
our um messed up human puny minds can
figure some of this stuff out with the
very help
of the thing that is being cognized that
is god so that is a lot uh to
throw at you i know
um i'm sure you've got some questions
or comments and comments could be well
this doesn't make any sense you know
which is an understandable response i
think
um to some of this that was great that's
a great uh great overview of not only
simplicity but anselm's take on the
incarnation
so i guess we'll move into the kind of
question comment phase here
um i can open it up
with a first one so we were wondering
while we were working through some of
the text i think most of us were using
the hack it but we have some different
versions yeah
so his he he starts off the monologian
with these two arguments
um getting to some sort of supreme good
and then getting to some sort of supreme
notion of being
yeah so we were wondering if you could
kind of walk us through how he gets to
this fundamental
good and this fundamental being
well so
the
the being
right is
coming in in uh
chapter uh three yes um
yeah so i mean
before i do that too i want to say it's
kind of cool that he doesn't like
as so many people would do let's start
with proving that god exists and then
once we've got that then we'll that'll
be the springboard to go forward on
everything
um instead he's like well let's let's
start with good
so
his argument here is that there has to
you know he he does sort of an analysis
of goods that you see him working out
and he's not trying to provide like a
complete theory but he says you know
there's different different types of
of ways in which things that are good
right
and
is there so later on he's going to say
who would doubt
um
that this thing through which all goods
exist is a very great good so he's going
to he's going to argue that that there
is something through which everything
is good is this a good argument by the
way not really you know
um
that might be part of why he wanted to
reappropriate that and rework it in the
monologuium
and so he says
he is good through himself since every
good exists through him
no good that exists through another is
equal to or greater than that good who
alone is good through himself now you
could say well what if there isn't any
such thing
right
what if everything is just good through
some other good
and he doesn't say it here but it seems
to be like an
uh an assumption that sooner or later
you have to hit something
that is like the bedrock the good
through which other things are good even
if we like made a really complex web of
let's call them participatory or causal
relations
you're going to have to sooner or later
have some sort of node that you wind up
hitting
that
that seems to be the argument there to
me
you know that that winds up giving us
the supreme
good and you know you could say well
there's a lot of assumptions built in
there aren't there right something
because you know what what if we're
wrong about the assumption that any good
platonist would make and actually i
think a lot of other traditions would
make that
whatever something is good through
whatever makes that thing good
let's call it so we've got thing b and
we'll call it thing a
if um
thing a is the is providing the reason
or whatever it is that thing b is good
thing a is going to be more good
right
there's an assumption there
that somehow the cause is going to be
greater than the effect
um is that
always warranted
uh i mean i could i could think of
philosophical
positions that would not make that
assumption
but maybe in the case of like
the supreme good
maybe that has to be the case
which sounds a little circular though
doesn't it
what do the rest of you think
does that sound circular to you
i think the supreme good is the the
supreme good because it's the supreme
good i mean if we put it like that
sounds
totally circular
yeah
yeah that is an interesting point i mean
this is
either you have a supreme good
that is a unity
or you have to have a whole bunch of
like
supreme goods and then you got to be
able to account for what's their
connection with each other and
are they
is one higher than the other well then
drop that one out of the picture right
um this is kind of a dynamic process of
thinking
i think
but just let me ask all of you is that
satisfying for you or not
because i go back and forth on this with
anselm you know just like with the
ontological argument sometimes i'm like
yeah that actually that's really good
and then sometimes i'm like
that's a there's something wrong with
this somewhere
now what is that a reflection of is that
a reflection of there being something
wrong with the
line of thinking or is that a reflection
of our own
problematic
status as
understanders
yeah i mean it's
yeah the example he gives is interesting
where um
he presents his own
potential counter example to the claim
that there's a single good
yeah from which everything
kind of uh
inherits its goodness he talks about um
a horse he says
um
uh let me see here the horse and the
robber right yeah yeah so it seems like
the horse is good because it's strong or
swift yeah
and
on the other hand um
the robber
uh
he can be
strong or swift and not be good
and so
it would seem to suggest that
um
there's kind of a multiplicity of ways
of being good i guess that's
the
conclusion well and there are you know
and and anselm
wants to recognize that there are a
multiplicity of ways of being good
um and he'll this will run throughout
his treatises there's there's you know
like in in terms of the will
there's the good as justice and the good
as the entire range of things that make
us happy that are gonna commodum in like
on the fall of the devil
but
that being so
doesn't mean that there can't be some
ultimate supreme good
that all of their goodnesses in some way
participate in
um
does he does he ever like provide a
systematic exposition of
how all these multiple modes of goodness
participated not really
but and he doesn't seem bothered by that
either which is kind of a funny thing
he does mention that you know
nothing is thought to be good except
because of a certain usefulness so
or because of some kind of excellence
honest yeah
yeah yeah so
yeah it was the idea like okay there
there would seem to be a multiplicity
you know this thing is good by being
swift that thing is good by being strong
but when you really analyze it um
both of those are actually good and so
far as they're both useful
in that particular context and thus we
kind of return to well in that context
yeah yeah
although that doesn't preclude some
things being
good by being um
honest
and you know the ancients had this
distinction between you know that comes
from from originally um
from like like aristotle
talking about the
good as useful good as pleasurable
good as as as uh cologne or as as
beautiful or as such that gets
translated almost immediately into latin
as
the utility the um
there's a bunch of different latin words
for the pleasurable
um and then the honest
the honest
just means like
intrinsically good you know
and
then later on and some will you know
bring in further distinctions like
justice by itself is something honest
but there's a whole range of things that
he calls um
the commodum
you know which could be useful or they
could be pleasant or they could also be
like good intrinsically but they're not
justice
in the dicta on cell me he actually
talks about um
there being three
different
not different three distinguishable
ranges of good justice
um
[Music]
the commodum
and then just being essay
you know so by being itself you're
already good which it kind of makes
sense you know
but any of them can be you know kind of
misappropriated so like you know what's
what's wrong with the robber being
swift and strong which normally we're
cool with well he's gonna use it for
evil you know
so it's it's not like the robbers
um swiftness by itself is no longer good
strictly speaking it's the perversion of
the
the good that he has you know i mean
actually let's transpose that rosslyn
you know and felt like sort of the the
archetypical bad guy for anselm uh one
of those you know dirty dialecticians
um he's not like you know by virtue of
of having a rational mind
or even having an imagination he's not a
bad guy because of that it's
the ways in which he's using it and
ordering it and then you know attacking
the church and
having somehow to write stuff
in response that that is actually bad
um
i mean this is this is sort of outside
the scope of this but you know and some
has a typically augustinian idea that
evil is just privation or corruption of
the the good right
i think that's consistent with his
thinking because he's got that
solution where he talks about god's
power i mean basically you you know the
famous objection that you get a lot of
times from internet atheists as well as
well if god's all-powerful why can't he
think dirty thoughts
that's a new one to me
i'd say i haven't been looking at
internet atheists for quite a while
because i i you know i i would get the
can he make a stone so heavy he can't
lift it you know kind of kind of
nonsense so is that is that where they
are now that
should be able to
yeah and anselm's response is well
that's not power that's weakness
i mean this is a little bit off topic
but i can think of a way in which god
could be said to think about dirty
thoughts like if god wants to um make me
a better person and i think dirty
thoughts then god is giving some thought
to how to get me to no longer think
dirty thoughts
he which is not him to thinking dirty
thoughts directly but
you know presumably he knows what he's
about so
yeah
some of the stuff that people bring up i
mean
again off the topic you wonder about the
motivations
you're like
do you really think that's a good
argument that you're making or are you
just like
you know doing the argument equivalent
of [ __ ] posting or
what's what's going on with that i mean
you know what's your motivation um are
you just trying to like get a rise out
of people or
you know
i mean but anselm would have an answer
to that he'd say look at you know you're
you're um trying to think your way
towards something that's already hard to
wrap our heads around and you're using
like some of the most
inadequate of tools to do so you know
you're bound to
to go astray in doing that
all right well alex you have a question
all right alex are you are you there or
did you
alex warren
oh silent al
i've got a question
all right we'll go to carson um
you were talking about how the
trinitarian persons
each of them
wholly
have justice
our justice or our justice so i was
wondering about that because that seems
like a problem
because if you say
god is justice
and it seems like you you forced to make
a distinction between
um
i mean you wouldn't say the persons
are justice and that's it i mean you're
distinct persons and they all
are justice as soon as you do that it
seems like you've got
a distinction
between
something in god and having justice or
being justice so i was wondering if you
could
maybe
elucidate a little bit what that
distinction is um maybe it's just a
distinction of
the person's
um and if that's the case
how does he think it's a distinction in
anselm um
and and for anselm
god whether we think of god as
you know the supreme um substance or
whether we think of god in in terms of
the trinitarian persons
um
god can't have justice because that
would be lesser than
um being justice
so it's not like there's justice first
in you know the divine substance and
then it gets parcelled out to each of
the members of the trinity
that that wouldn't work at all
um for conceptualizing
what's going on there each by virtue of
each of these persons of the trinity
being entirely god
um
every one of these attributes is
entirely what they are but it also gives
us a kind of
like i mentioned a as he says a
repetition or
[Music]
you know a
replication or
intensive reflexive reflexivity
in each of these attributes
you know i wonder about like being a
creator or something that relates to
creation
would that
be
not intrinsically the same as god and
then you have a distinction between
attributes well it's not it's not
not intrinsically the same as god
because god is the creator right
it's not like first
there's god and then
god's like what kind of god do i want to
be
let's create
um there just is that and and creation
for anselm
is
involving
both persons of the trinity or the both
of the first two people of the trinity
persons election people of the trinity
we're the people of the trinity right um
because the the word is the
um
everything that exists exists in the
word before it's created
you know
but it's the word is not doing the
creating it's
the father who's creating
but you know it's just like you know
god gives instructions to the word or
you know says hey
give me the blueprints no it's not like
that i mean we use all these
these ideas that we draw from our own um
as anselm would say imagination
and none of them are none of them are
adequate to the ineffable way as he
calls it that this is happening you know
and you know strictly speaking too
the holy spirit's lurking around there
somewhere too in
in creation
but he doesn't he doesn't tell us
anything about that
thank you very much i was wondering also
um
there's this argument in
proclass where
you need a distinct
monad
to account for any distinct class of
things so for like for example all
beings or all living things
or all things that have capacity for
intellect
yeah that would require a distinct monad
sort of like a form to account for that
so you would need for example being
life and wisdom as sort of like
prior forms to all the classes of beings
living things and wisdom
and for for proclass
you know these prior forms have to be
distinct from each other to account for
the distinctness of the different
classes and so therefore
um being life and wisdom for example
will not be the same as
the one or god for propolis and in
dionysius
uh he has
you know the the main processions that
he talks about in the divine names
uh after the good are being life and
wisdom
so i was wondering if on some
would disagree with that argument and
say no you know being life and wisdom
that just is god and they're all the
same
yeah that's exactly what anselm does
that's what's going on in those parts of
the monologian that we we looked at and
then he just reiterates that over and
over again in the pro-slogan and
basically anytime anselm
has a chance in one of his treatises to
consider
two things that we would
predict about god
which are god
he stresses not only that they are god
like you know god is the very life by
which he lives god is the very wisdom by
which she is wise etc but that they are
the same thing in some way
so he he is he's rejecting
any sort of
ultimate distinction between them and
this is where you know
um
i mean it's
what you could say is there's there's a
kind of um you either got to go this way
or go this way in platonism itself right
because this is a really central
important thing
if you do believe that there are these
unities or forms or whatever you want to
call them
um
are they
distinct from each other
or are they
all in
one thing you know like for example
um
ascetic is not a platonist but seneca
will talk about the you know
platonic forms and say that they exist
in the mind of god you know
uh as the seminar the um
uh
seminal reasons
um
that's one option right another option
would be like what you're talking about
with proclass where no these have to be
distinct from each other and maybe they
can even be arranged hierarchically or
something like that right
and then you've got somebody like anselm
and i also think augustine
fits in there as well
where
these um these all have to be what god
is
and
when we're looking at them you know it's
not it's not impossible to look at
things
as
say pro close would but that would be a
mistaken point of view from anselm's
point of view um about about how these
it's it's mistaken about god it's also
mistaken about how
um
supreme justice supreme life supreme you
know all these things
um
relate to each other
you know yeah i think that's interesting
you know dionysius i think
divine names five
one
um the god is sort of the possessor of
these divine names or processions yeah
yeah so it seems like anthem might say
well hold on a second you can't really
possess you know being life and wisdom
uh yet be somehow beyond it
i mean well you're not even beyond it
you are it
so
and the reason you can't possess it is
just because you've already got you've
already
you notice i almost slipped into the the
having language there right
you already are it in a superlative way
the bet the the most just way that
justice can be is
is god so just having
justice would be a step down
you know
it gets really trippy and justice is
pretty easy for us to think about that
way but now think about three other
things
being
simplicity or unity
and eternity
god
is being
god doesn't have being because to have
being would be less than being being you
know
boy that's a hard thing to wrap your
head around for me at least
um
unity is even tougher and eternity i
think is which i've mentioned just a
little bit is even even tougher
um
but it's you know it's a good thing for
us to try to
challenge ourselves with and and i think
to to go to your question maybe what we
have to talk about here are like
fundamental
decisions that have to be made within
the the grand platonic tradition about
which way you go on on understanding
these things you know
yep yeah and i think that that helps to
kind of get enzo's position so thank you
sure all right so alex had a question
that he wasn't able to ask because of
his sound and then we'll move julian
walker so alex wants to ask in the chat
does anselm use the term spiration for
the procession of the holy spirit from
the father and the son as aquinas does
and what if he does does this mean
he doesn't use that um
he just uses you know the word
procession
um what does spiration mean i mean
i'm not a good person to answer that
because just looking at it it's it's
essentially a cognate for spirit like
it's becoming spirit
um it's it's kind of a weird way to
think about
i mean what the hell does proceeding
need though i mean
it's
both of these terms that we use in in
the trinity
talking about the relations like so
baguettes generates
you know
but it's not born like we're he's
thinking of of being born
whatever the hell is going on there has
got to be you know
something
quite impressive if we could ever think
it but
we don't really know what it is we're
gesturing at it with metaphorical
language proceeding gives you the idea
of like like
walking from something or
you know
i mean i guess one of the hints is that
the holy spirit is love between the
father and the son right so
that's there in both anselm and aquinas
so
loving is is
it like in its fullest sense
um
is uh
something that like overflows from
the two i mean the thing is that none of
these
take place in time
as anselm stresses
and and aquinas thinks as well
um the holy spirit has always
been just as much as the son just as
much as the father
um
anselm actually like clarifies that in
on the incarnation of the word and on
the processional holy spirit there was
never any point in time when
these relations that we talk about
happening so i don't have a good answer
for that at all i think
well that's all good that's all helpful
thank you i appreciate it
i'm extraordinarily surprised that it
was because there must be something
going on in your brain
that's uh
doing better than what's in mind when it
comes to that because i i don't
understand it so
oh no you're good i mean i've mainly
read aquinas's discussion of the trinity
in the summa
and your analysis of anselm's uh
understanding of the trinity did help me
to kind of make some more sense of what
aquinas is saying in there
you know i will say this about the
connection between aquinas and some um
aquinas brings up anselm quite a bit
in the summer um there's like entire
sections where he's like on the
discussion of original sin where he's
going to say anselm basically has this
right
you know um or the discussions of uh
truth
and august
aquinas is trying to take um
what what anselm has provided and go a
bit further with it so
um
i don't know maybe maybe he brings
anselm up in that although there's
there's other there's so many other
people have written on the trinity right
the boethius and
augustine and
so by the time that aquinas is on the
scene there's so many people to draw
upon
so tucker did you have your hand raised
before
yeah you know i think he probably went
through one of my questions so i'll let
julian go okay go for it
all right can you guys hear me all right
yeah
okay wonderful yeah well as something of
an internet atheist myself i'm probably
having some of the hardest time here uh
wrapping my head around this but um
so to start off my question i can kind
of understand how
we can arrive at
um like a finitude in one god from these
infinite number of attributes
how all of these attributes become one
and the same attribute in god but then
it seems to me there's almost kind of uh
another degree of finitude reinserted in
that through the trinity right that the
trinity of personhood which complicates
it for me
i assume anselm is not just trying to
take this doctrine of simplicity and
mesh it with
the trinity after the fact
so maybe to pose the question another
way
for anselm does the
triune nature of god have kind of a
necessity
is
the idea of god necessarily trinitarian
that's the whole point of the monologue
okay if you can parse that out a little
bit more
why is god necessarily
trinitarian i mean that's that's
like argumentation from
what like chapter
i mean it's not there isn't a parse it
out here
um
let me see here so
you could say that it begins from
chapter 29 and runs all the way to
chapter 63
right
that's what's going on in the monologue
i mean the pro-slogan provides a
shorter
not really argument for it more just
like an exposition for it
um
but there isn't a like well here's
here's the simple argument for why god
has to be a trinity
but going back to like the i don't know
that that finitude is is
the idea that you want
um there's a multiplicity
from our perspective of divine
attributes that doesn't mean that that's
what's in god a multiplicity
all of these attributes are what god is
which turns out to be
a super unity a unity
that goes beyond what we typically think
of as unity you know
these are difficult things to
to conceptualize
you know
i wonder if he makes more like a defense
that the trinity is like not against
reason and does maybe he starts with his
faith or or do you think
he's going so far as to like rationally
deduce the trinity because it seems like
you were saying he doesn't want to
either i would say it's neither he's not
deducing
um
because he's not providing some sort of
you know like straightforward simple
syllogistic deductive argument i mean
it's it's running like i said it's
running through
uh
probably half of the monologium
um
and he's you know sort of taking stabs
at it from this side and this side and
then looking at this and looking at this
and
um there's there's a i mean dialectical
would be a better way of describing
what's what's happening there
and yeah he is starting from faith but
starting from faith means a lot of
different things it can people start
from faith by
taking stuff out of the bible and using
it as premises in an argument that they
take as like incontrovert
you incontrovertible starting points and
some would say that's terrible theology
and terrible philosophy you actually
have to figure out what the hell the you
know scripture passages actually mean
and a lot of the time they don't mean
what the ordinary person thinks that
they mean according to anselm he he's
this is why he gets accused of being a
rationalist by some people
he he goes so far as to say yeah when we
understand scripture we have to
understand you know what actually makes
sense not you know
not the surface level
uh thing that might be leading us astray
which sometimes would get people kind of
scared i think
hearing that
um
so he's
he's not trying to provide a
defense he's not engaging in apologetics
or anything like that
again you know what was the the whole
point of the monologian this is the
stuff anselm was teaching
as prior to these monks as meditations
on the nature of the divine substance
and
he
didn't want to write them down and they
kept on
bugging him until he finally
said all right fine i'll write a book
for you here here you go it's the
monologian you know um
[Music]
so i mean he's he's he's not somebody
who neatly fits into
the ways in which we typically you know
categorize
um
let's call them activities
um
he thinks that god has given us a you
know rational minds so that we can
make our way to understanding him he
thinks that we we do have to start from
some sort of basis of faith but that
basis we'd better
make it you know way more secure than
the rudimentary
messed up you know half picture thinking
starting points that we
we uh begin from
and that god would be
he wouldn't say pissed off i'm i'm going
to say that god would be pissed off at
us for like squandering our intellectual
resources by just
appealing to the bible or something like
that
as a a stop gap you know
so how are are you free to go a few more
minutes or are you sure okay
actually if you don't mind i do have a
question sure
so um probably the most prominent uh in
in the last 300 years objections to
anselm's argument particularly in the
proslogian is uh is kant right and so i
think i've gotten a good enough sense
about you might just say like go little
emmanuel right uh you know like you're
we're not predicating being yeah but
it god is being but i i'm still trying
to make sense of like
does do you think does the is the
objection just completely misunderstood
so const objection in the critique
doesn't target anselm's argument at all
it targets descartes spinoza people like
that
anselm didn't produce an ontological
argument it's never called that until
kant's time
and what's going on in descartes and
spinoza
is quite different than what's happening
in pro-slogan 2-4 you know
um
that you know quo maya's kogitari known
positive being the linchpin is really
the central thing to his argument
it's not as even even aquinas by the way
in um
somatiologia gets anselm wrong
um
because
anselm is not saying deus
deus este or deus essa is piercing
that's not his his argument at all
he's saying if you think out the
implications of god being
komaeus kogitari known posted that then
which nothing greater can be thought if
you like linger with that idea you wind
up seeing that god has to not only
it's interesting too because he uses the
language of essay there being but he
also uses deus vera existed at the end
of
chapter two god you know
truly
exists you know with existence being
something
perhaps uh more intensive than just mere
being so anselm's doing his own weird
wacky thing over here and then you know
people like descartes and
spinoza come along and say yeah you know
god's
god's
essence necessarily you know includes
existence or god's idea has to be that
of something that necessarily exists and
that's that's more what kant is
targeting there
in his lectures on theology kant
actually does target anselm's argument
um
a bit more more closely and i don't
remember it's been a long time since
i've read that
interestingly
is all those of you who've read through
the critique of pure reason know that
kant is not um going after the
ontological argument just to knock that
down he's also claiming that if you if
you show the ontological argument
doesn't work
the cosmological
and the um
design argument the teleological
argument they both presume that so you
knock out all three with one blow you
know
but
kant doesn't appear to
um
make at least to me what's a very you
know convincing
counter argument um he he hits what he's
targeting but that's not
every
ontological argument you could say right
um
and then you know hegel comes along he's
got a great retort to kant saying
um not the existence is not a predicate
thing but that you know a hundred
um imaginary dollars is uh
uh
you know 100 real dollars 100 imaginary
dollars so hegel says makes a big
difference whether one's in your pocket
or not doesn't it you know and so
there's is that a great retort no but
there's something to that you know um
[Music]
but i mean the ontological argument is
uh
it's an interesting one
anselm's wounded argumentum is not
proslogen 2-4
because the unum argumentum is supposed
to show three things that god exists or
is
that god is the supreme good
um
that all other things need in order to
be good right which sounds very
neoplatonic
and that um all the other things that we
believe about god which is sort of a
miscellaneous junk drawer right um and
it's supposed to be a
resume or resuming of of the monologian
and condensing it all
into one unum argumentum
and that is the totality of the
proslogian
perhaps including chapter one which is a
prayer
all the way to the last three chapters
the three chapters are conjectures
he calls them cognectiones
and so they're not actually part of the
argument they're like adjuncts to it but
everything else
is
part of that unum argument
um
[Music]
which means that you know
if anselm is making an ontological
argument that's sort of a
um a side piece
you know
so i've always when i'm reading that
i've always thought that there are two
key things you gotta get your mind
around and the first is
really speaking to the formula of that
than which nothing greater can be
conceived
because that implies this sort of
limit case and then beyond and continue
beyond and then the other thing is that
i think the key assumption and i could
be wrong about this is that it's greater
to be in reality than in the mind and
that's like the driving force making the
jump so that's that's one of the places
where you could attack it you could say
like well you know um
let's think about nerve gas
you know it's it's uh i don't you know i
can like imagine the room here being
filled up with nerve gas
and you know dying from nerve gas is a
horrible way to go when i when i was in
the army
uh you know 30 years ago we had to learn
what the symptoms of nerve gas poisoning
were because we were worried that the
soviets would use it on us and get all
paranoid you know because you'd like
think maybe you had some of them that's
horrible stuff right so i can i can like
keep that in my mind and let's not have
that in reality it's not greater than
that in reality right and so you could
say well what about problems like that
or like you know the room being filled
up with spiders um i mean i like spiders
but i wouldn't want a room that's all
wrigley spiders biting me and stuff like
that
so you know then you have to like think
your way through it and i think this may
be something that anselm would be cool
with
you know the
these meditations which is what the pro
slogan and the monologuine are are not
designed to be treatises that you know
answer every single thing but provide us
with like almost like a catalyst for our
own dynamic thinking about this kind of
stuff maybe we have to then say all
right put those
kinds of
um
worries aside
what about something that is truly great
you know is for at least for that is it
is it greater to exist in reality than
to exist in the mind maybe we have to do
some qualification
in order to make
anselm's argument work maybe he's a
little bit too um
too uh old in the formulation there and
this jibes with his response to ganilo
because ganilo you know brings up that
well i can think of a logically and not
logically but
you know a perfect island um the
logically perfect that's like 20th
century language that gets used by
people like uh
planting uh
and heart short and you know later
interpreters of anselm's argument but
you know um anselm says well
what you're trying to do here i see you
know what you're saying
it doesn't work in the case of an island
it does work in the case of god
um
maybe that's what we have to do if if we
buy into it like i said you know
i've been
grappling with anselm's argument now for
roughly 30 years
and
i go back and forth on it you know i i
don't know what what about the rescue do
you
buy it or not or
you know do you find it uh now anselm
himself
in the process of working on it
at one point you know if you read the
prologue to it thought that it might be
a tool of the devil to distract him from
prayers
you know
so
all that that wavering back and forth
maybe uh
maybe that's not a good thing
i mean i think that like in reading a
lot of secondary lit so i know a lot of
tomists give it a really bad rap
because it's not st thomas yeah yeah
yeah well it's it seems to be it's very
strange because at one of our domestic
meetings we tried to understand why
thomas rejects it in prima pars ii
yeah and
it it i i just a lot of us that were
there we could not understand why and it
seems to have something to do with how
the argument or at least as thomas
portrays it assume that you know the
divine essence which you don't
but yeah anselm never makes that move
like
explicitly he never makes that move and
so
i did go and look at the psalm the
commentary on the psalms that you've had
and aquinas does in there seem a lot
more open to some type of argument like
anselm is giving well he says that
anselm actually
is correct
but he's still framing it there in terms
of and some saying that deus essa
is something that's pierce a nota right
that
you know
the
the predicate is contained in in the
subject is the way thomas likes to talk
about and that's that's what sort of set
the agenda all the way to const time
right
uh to go to the other question
um
thomas thinks that
and some you know
um claiming that that uh deus essa
um
is per se noted that's that's correct
but it's only per se nota to the
sapientes to the wise
and so it's not going to be a good um
argument to make the ordinary people
right
it's definitely not what you're so if
the beginning of your soma teologia has
to start after you've you know explained
the different kinds of readings of
scripture with proofing that the thing
that you want to talk about actually
exists this is not going to be the way
to do it because you're you know who's
the summit actually written for it's not
written for the sapientes the the wise
it's i mean we we think of it as a tough
text it's actually written for
incapientes beginners
so
you know
um
aquinas is you know basically saying
yeah okay and some that that whole idea
of like pulling god's
pulling something out of the idea of god
to show that it you know that being
necessarily exists that works but it's
not going to work for the people that
you have to target at the beginning
we got to go about things a different
way and then you know aquinas is also
interested in
exploring causality
you know and and it's not just let's get
that over with with the five ways and
then we'll move on to all the cool stuff
that parish priests need to know
um
the five ways kind of set the agenda for
thomas's whole approach to
um how
the creative
trinity
engages
with the with us and the rest of
creation and how we can know you know um
something about that being through
through the effects that we see here you
know enough to guide our our actions and
decisions and stuff like that
so it you know it kind of makes sense
that he would you know he would reject
and some not because he thinks oh and
some you're just totally wrong you know
throw you in the flames to use hume's uh
uh famous phrase right
get rid of anselm's books no he he
appropriates and some over and over and
over again on points where he thinks
that he's uh helpful to bring into the
the structure of the summa lugia
but anselm's prosologian argument just
isn't
gonna it's gonna be kind of a
non-starter you know
but somebody else who has that point of
view john locke
um
about uh descartes
argument
um there's kind of a three prong
tradition
that runs throughout
the history of philosophy when it comes
to whatever we want to call ontological
arguments
and you've got one where they're like
yeah ontological arguments they work
here here's a version of it so you got
anne's film in the middle ages and a few
other people as well picking up on him
and then descartes you know very
famously and then hegel and each one is
like a totally different animal you know
and then you've got this no way this is
this is garbage you know get rid of it
and so you got ganilo
and then you got pure gasendi and the
the
modern period doing so for descartes and
then you've got kant right
and then you've got this more pragmatic
like well it's a great argument too bad
nobody's going to buy it well that
includes thomas and lock you know
so you've got at least three different
possible
ways of going at the ontological
argument you know
in a serious way i mean you could have a
non-serious way like you know saying
uh
this is just uh silly nonsense or
something like that which is not quite
the same thing as what the rejectors are
doing
so
all right well do we have any more uh
maybe one more final question
i think if if cars carson do you have
you have some thoughts
uh maybe the last thing i would ask is
you know all this supreme being talk in
on some would probably raise some flags
with people
yeah concerned with onto theology this
question of god's being
sort of being comparable to creatures
being
yeah yeah yeah platonius might want to
say well no god is a completely
transcendent unity that's beyond being
um
what would be the answer to that would
he speak of analogy would he speak of
university does he even have these terms
or he doesn't use those terms at all now
um but it's not supreme being supreme
ascencia that we translate as supreme
being and that's only one of like you
know
for example in monologian 16 of like 18
different supreme things
you know and each one is conceived of as
a in a dynamic way so supreme ascentia
is the same thing as supreme ends and
ends is not like an entity it's like
being you know you're doing something
but god is just as much supreme justice
or you know
here's a weird one supreme refuge
supreme you know supreme solace what the
hell is that you know um and he's not
he's not like he's more supreme being
than he is all these other
supremes and you know and anselm has
pointed out too supreme is a relative
term
he said well why do you use it so much
then
ah you know it's just kind of a
marker um
you could just as easily instead of
saying supreme um justice say as he does
you stitia existence
um
you know whatever
whatever is at the top of the hierarchy
you know
now is that it's a rate that's a great
uh question is that beyond
being
in an onto you know
with being being conceived of an onto
theological way
um
i don't know i haven't i haven't given
that much thought um
i mean interestingly i know mario has a
piece on handsome but i it's been a long
time since i've read it
um
i i mean i would suspect that what's
going on in anselm is not
what heidegger called onto theology
um
[Music]
and heidegger was pretty fast and loose
with with that term and heidegger made
some like huge sweeping assumptions of
his own
and
deploying
that against what he calls epochal
metaphysics you know
with christianity essentially being
summed up as
a new conception of being
um
which you know places the supreme being
god as you know creating out of nothing
and then everything following from from
that i think heidegger's um
depiction of
christian thought is kind of deficient
[Music]
but i mean here we're getting way out of
my area of competence so
thanks a lot appreciate it oh sure
awesome well i think this is a good
place to end so
um
i would like to thank dr sadler for
joining us and again you can check out
his his papers on academia edu phil
people etc and um
his book is in the uga library so
unfortunately we have to find a way to
make it cheaper
i looked and it's catholic university of
america press is probably never gonna
make it cheaper
and because of that it will never make
it to paperback stage because there's
there's a vicious circle right you have
to sell enough hardcover copies at the
way too high price
in order for them to think that there
would be a market for cheaper paperback
versions and then they would consider
publishing it
i mean if they would just like bring it
out in paperback
you know for i don't know
25 or 30 bucks they'd make a ton of
money on that but they're never going to
do it because they've got this
interesting logic
that precludes that so
i just want to say that uh i just
started watching your youtube videos
this past week um so i i'm i'm really
interested in the existentialists so
i've been uh working my way through that
so it's great to meet you thanks for
thanks for joining us you're very
welcome yeah there's there's a lot of
content there
um on various existentialists there's
also some huge gaps you know uh i'm
great for like projecting a project that
i'm gonna work on and then getting about
a quarter of it done and then moving on
to something else something that maybe
some of you can relate to you know in
different proportions
yeah
well again thank you and um hopefully
we'll be able to talk again sometime on
uh anselm dionysius maybe somebody like
blondel who so dr sadler did his
dissertation on maurice blondell by the
way which is uh
one of the few blondel experts right
yeah there's not a ton of them out there
because there's not a lot of reader of
blondel unfortunately
so yeah well thanks very much for
having me here i'm glad to
contribute something to such an
interesting
new initiative and i hope that things
continue to grow
thanks for the questions and comments
i've got some good things to think about
you